la statue de victor schoelcher trônant
devant l'ancien palais de justice de
fort-de-france renversé par une poignée
de militants sur les images les auteurs
dabach aucun signe distinctif
particulier même si l'on voit sur
certains des t-shirts aux imprimés
rouge-vert-noir sur cette autre vidéo
captées depuis un autre angle en perçoit
la détermination des activistes il
s'acharne de longues secondes sur la
statue une quinzaine d'entre eux la
renverse à la force des bras à
schoelcher le même sort est réservé à la
statue de celui qui a donné son nom à la
commune situé juste à l'entrée du bourg
dans un cas comme dans l'autre les
militants pour quelques uns ont agi à
visage découvert les cordes et les
outils d'utiliser de même que la date du
22 mai suggère un acte prémédité
parfaitement assumé victor schoelcher
est considéré par un grand nombre comme
un abolitionniste ayant permis la
signature du décret d'abolition de
l'esclavagé mais le personnage et les
hommages qui lui sont rendus sont
remises en cause par d'autres qui prône
avant tout la mise en lumière des
révoltes anti esclavagiste